Sometimes, everything goes right.
Sometimes, all the pieces are in the perfect
position.
Your teammates.
Your opponents.
All of them are arranged, just right.
Sometimes, all the decisions you make, lead
up to one perfect moment.
Sometimes, when the moment is just right,
you can show the world what it takes to win
six million dollars, through skill and trust
alone.
[Caster audio]
Evil Geniuses were considered one of the strongest
Dota 2 teams in the world, heading into
The International 5.
Despite kicking off the year by losing two
of their strongest players,
Artour “Arteezy” Babaev
and Ludwig “zai” Wahlberg,
ppd: Nobody wanted to play with us, everyone thought that we were on the losing end of this Western shuffle
EG still managed to win the Dota 2 Asia Championships
with the help of
Kurtis “Aui_2000” Ling
and a young, unproven pubstar named
Syed “SumaiL” Hassan.
EG went on to place second at The Summit 3
and ESL One Frankfurt, putting them on track
to be the one of the favorites heading into
TI5.
EG finished first in their group, and moved
on to the bracket stage, when they beat compLexity
and EHOME, qualifying for the upper bracket
finals.
But it was there that EG faced their first
true challenge all tournament.
CDEC Gaming went undefeated in the wild card
stage,
[Caster audio]
and placed second in their group — second
only to EG.
But CDEC beat both Cloud9 and LGD-Gaming 2-0
to make it to the Winners’ Finals,
where they trounced EG 2-0.
ppd: We kind of thought we knew how to play against  them
we kind of thought we could handle their playstyle but we were totally wrong.
Fear: Everything just started going wrong for us. Like, we overestimated, like our own abilities.
And we underestimated them, and they just completely destroyed us in that best-of-two.
It was a very fast 2-0.
EG dropped down to the lower bracket and
beat LGD 2-0
to earn another shot at CDEC.
EG took Game 1, but CDEC fought back, taking
Game 2 and keeping it close.
[Caster audio]
EG rallied in Game 3, but Game 4 was where
EG made magic happen.
Aui_2000: Going back in to face CDEC in the Grand Finals,
it was really useful that we lost to them in the Winners' Finals.
Just because we were able to sort of predict what they wanted to do in the games.
They wanted to do like, invade our jungle. We knew what they would ban, we knew
that they weren't strong with Leshrac. We had a lot of key points of information that we could use.
Throughout the series, EG targeted Agressif,
forcing him to play his weaker heroes.
It put EG at an advantage through most of
the series.
[Caster audio]
ppd: I think this threw them off a lot because they expected us to first pick Naga Siren.
Because that's one of our best heroes.
And they thought they were going to get Gyrocopter for Agressif.
But we knew that they didn't play Naga, we had no reason to prioritize it.
When Gyropcopter is just like such a deny pick from them.
CDEC was forced to let SumaiL back on his signature
Storm Spirit.
[Caster audio]
And to prevent him from wreaking havoc, they
tried to focus him.
[Caster audio]
With SumaiL down, CDEC was desperate, so they
needed to move fast.
They rushed for Roshan, hoping they could
win the ensuing fight 4v5.
[Caster audio]
With CDEC so grouped up, ppd and Universe’s
combo utterly shredded their health bars.
[Russian caster audio]
Effectively winning the game then and there.
[Korean caster audio]
EG couldn’t see all of CDEC in the pit,
in fact, Universe was effectively going in blind.
But he trusted his intuition.
He trusted his team.
Universe: We didn't have vision of them at the time. But then I told ppd to throw
in an Ice Vortex.
And he threw it in there and I saw a couple of them so I just assumed they'd all be in there
and I just made a blind leap of faith.
And then they were all in there, and they all died.
An Echo Slam hits every enemy around the Earthshaker,
which means teams tend to avoid grouping up against him.
But either out of desperation or confidence,
CDEC were in the perfect position for
the biggest Echo Slam in Dota history.
[Caster audio]
Universe: I just yelled. I don't even know what sound came out of my mouth,
but it was pretty loud.
It wasn’t just a huge play, it was a championship-winning
play.
It single-handedly won EG the tournament and
finally gave NA Dota some recognition.
EG hasn’t quite been the same team since
they won TI, but the Echo Slam lives on as
one of the biggest plays in Dota 2 history.
It lives on as a reminder that trust and teamwork
can always win a championship.